for 3 days this low-lying Coastal area
in Northern Lebanon was inundated when
nearby Rivers overflowed during heavy
rains the waters may have receded but
people's lives have been turned upside
down many homes suffered extensive
damage n Al Ali tells us the water
reached up to her
waist those living here are some of the
most vulnerable in Lebanon where the
economy has all but
collapsed I lost everything I have
nothing left I don't know where I'm
going to stay relatives will let you
stay for a few days but then what many
here lost their
livelihoods they are demanding
compensation from those in power who
they accuse of corruption and neglecting
deteriorating
infrastructure every year they make
promises and do nothing They Don't Care
About Us as you can see we are not able
to deal with this crisis alone days of
heavy rain transformed roads into rivers
of mud there are several informal
settlements for refugees from
neighboring Syria in this region as well
tents were submerged by water that Rose
quickly hundreds of families were saved
but many are again
homeless this is the first time we
experienced something like this all of a
sudden the water level Rose I had to be
rescued by the Lebanese Army people here
say the floods is the worst they have
seen in years and it's now happening
each year the river's water level
reached up to here experts say global
climate change is leading to intense
bouts of rain after long periods of dry
weather and that's also contributing to
the crisis but there are others who
point the blame on the lack of
infrastructure and barriers along the
course of the
rivers we have been telling the
authorities for years that they need to
build proper BMS if they do that then we
wouldn't have this recurring problem
concern is growing among communities
living here near the banks of two rivers
that the worst is yet to come and more
bad weather is forecast for next week
zenah Al jazer Northern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz